طبعا اشياء كثيره تغيرت خلال السنوات يعني
على مستوى الشخصي وعلى المستوى العام
على مستوى البلدان اللي شهد الكثير من
التحولات والماثر
على مستوى المغرب ايضا صافي تطورات كثيره
عند حسن نجمه ما هو
تغير طعمه الشاي ااااه
فغير
[موسيقى]
العلاقه الشخصيه مع الفضاء ومع الزمن
ومع النفس ومع الاخرين ومع اللغه ايضا
لم اعد ذلك الفتى الذي كنته مستوى
الاقتناعات المستوى الافكار يعني بس مستوى
سيروره الكتابه
الزمن
يشتغل في الذات يشتغل في الواعي يشتغل في
في اللاعيعي اللاوعي هنا بالمعنى الفريدي
ليس بمعنى الغيبوبه يعني
همم
الزمن ليس سهلا يفعل فعله يفعل فعله
العميق ويغير اقتناعات ويغير الكثير من
الافكار وبالخصوص اقتناعاتنا المتورمه
مستوى السياسي
ونتعلم من الزمن من ما يوفره لنا من خيبان
خيبات ليست دائما
صناعه مدمره الخيبات والاخفاق ايضا من
اخفاق الى اخر نتعلم كيف نواصل الحياه